ก็สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องอาร์ทตี้
นักเรียนวัดดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนอ่าครับผม
สวัสดีค่าก็พบกับครูเอ๋และน้องอาร์ตี้นะ
คายครับวันนี้กี่โมงคะตอนนี้ใช่ไหมครับ
ตอนนี้ตอนนี้
8:00 นครึ่งนมาตอนนี้ครึ่งทุ่มครึ่งใช่
ครับหม้อมืดเถอะเนาะๆมืดแล้วเนี่ยนะอ่า
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
โอเค
8:30 นน
8:30 น PM เนาะอ่ะอ่าใช่ครับ 20:30 น
ครับ 20:30 นนะคะเอ้าครู Arty ก็เอ้าเวลา
กลางวันไปออฟฟิศใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับเวลากลาง
วันแวะไปออฟฟิศๆกลับมาตอนนี้กลับมาที่
บ้านที่บ้านนายมากคุยกับครูเอ๋เอ๋นะคะได้
ครับคุยกับนักเรียนด้วยค่ะครูแอฟตี้วัน
นี้วันอะไรคะอ๋ออ๋อวันนี้วันนี้วันพุธ
ครับวันนี้วันพุธวันพุธหน้าวันพุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันนี้วันที่
น้าวันที่ 17 วันนี้วันพุธวันที่ 17
เดือนอะไรคะเหงาวันพุธที่ 17 เดือน
พฤศจิกายนครับเดือน
พฤศจิกายนๆๆปีพตเท่าไหร่คะปีพตต 2564
นะครับ
2564 ๆใช้ครับปีคศเท่าไหร่คะนี่คอย
ต2013 22
11 อาหาร
a2e  4 ไม่ใช่
2021 นะคะอ้าไทรงาม 2  21  11  25 ได้
ครับโอเค
วันนี้วันพุธวันที่ 17 รายงานวันอะไรคะก็
พรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัสบดีมีพรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัส
ครับ
วันนี้วันพุธวันที่ 17 พรุ่งนี้วัน
พฤหัสบดีวันที่เท่าไหร่คะอ้าพรุ่งนี้วัน
พฤหัสบดีวันที่
18 ครับอ้อพรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัสบดีวันที่ 18
ผู้ชายวันพุธพรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัสบดีหมายถึง
นี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อคืนนี้วันที่
มัน
วันศุกร์ครับ
วันศุกร์สายครับนี้วันศุกร์วันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะหมอมะรืนนี้วันศุกร์วันที่
19 ครับวันที่ 19 นะคะได้วันพุธวันนี้
วันพุธพรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัสบดีมะรืนนี้วัน
ศุกร์วันศุกร์เสร็จแล้ววันต่อไปวันอะไรคะ
วันศุกร์แล้ววันต่อไปวันเสาร์ครับอ๋ออ๋อ
วันต่อไปวันเสาร์วันที่เท่าไหร่นะคะวัน
เสาร์วันที่
20 ครับวันที่เตือนฉันเสาร์เสร็จแล้ววัน
ต่อไปวันอะไรคะหาวันเสาร์แล้ววันต่อไปวัน
อาทิตย์ครับวันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันอาทิตย์วันที่
21 ครับเอามาหา 21 ทรายครับครู Arty วัน
วันจันทร์วันอังคารวันพุธวันพฤหัสบดีวัน
ศุกร์พี่ไปออฟฟิศใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับ of ใคร
ทำงานๆไปทำงานที่ออฟฟิศน่ะมันตันวัน
อังคารวันพุธวันพฤหัสวันศุกร์ไปที่ออฟฟิศ
ครับจากบ้านแล้วก็ไปออฟฟิศใช่ไหมคะ 5
size ครับจากบ้านไปออฟฟิศ
มีบ้านหมู่บ้านนาจากบักฮ้านไป
ออฟฟิศหน้าที่ออฟฟิศเป็นแบบนี้ 5 ออฟฟิศ
โอเคถ้ามาหาแล้ววันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์ครู
Arty ไปออฟฟิศไหมคะอ้าวันเสาร์วันเสาร์
วันอาทิตย์ไม่ไปออฟฟิศไม่ไปครับวันวัน
เสาร์วันอาทิตย์ครู Arty ไม่ไปออฟฟิศ
อ่ะวันหยุดไม่ไปออฟฟิศไปครับ
วันหยุดเนี่ยครู Arty ไม่ไปออฟฟิศอ่ะครู
อ่ะตี้ไปไหนคะก็เปิดติว่าคลิปว่าวันหยุด
อยากไปทะเลเขาทะเลอ้าทะเลครูเอ๋อยากดู
ทะเลอยากมาดูทะเลขวดอี้มีรูปทะเล
โอเค
นี่นี่
ทำไมแน่
โห
กลัวจะมีอะไรบ้างคะครู Arty ดีทะเลมี
น้ำมีน้ำทะเลทะเลน้ำทะเลเนี่ย
ดื่มได้ไหมน้ำทะเลดื่มไม่ได้ทำไมได้น้ำ
ทะเลเค็ม
เค็มใช้เขาโอเคไม่ได้ดื่มไม่ได้แล้วถ้า
น้ำทะเลมาเป็นเครื่องมีลมลมแล้วก็พัดสี
ขาวขาวเป็นฟองฟอง 5 ลมพัดน้ำทะเลแบบนี้
อ่ะเราเรียกว่าคลื่น
เมื่อคืนหน้าไส้เขาเป็นชื่อหนูโอ้
มีมีทะเลมีน้ำทะเล
สีฟองคลื่นขาวๆเป็นอะไรคะ 5 ตรงนี้ใช่ไหม
ครับใช่ค่ะอ้าเห็นเป็น
อาชาชายหาด 5z เป็นทรายนะคะทรายใช่ครับมี
ทรายอยู่ตรงนี้อ้าอายนะทรายหาดทรายนะคะ
หาดทรายโอเคใช้หาดโอเคนะคะโอ้ทะเลแล้วไป
จนสุดสูตรขอตรงโน้น
ไปลายตรงโน้นอ่ะเป็นข้างบนอะไรข้างบนเป็น
เมฆเป็นเมฆนะครับแม่ make อยู่ที่ไหนคะ
เมฆอยู่บนท้องฟ้าสาขาผมขออ่าตั้งบนตรงนี้
มีเป็นท้องฟ้าฟ้านะครับบนท้องฟ้ามีเมฆ
อาใช้ครับว้าว
สวยค่ะกู Arty หวยใช่ไหมครับอ่า
อยากไปว่ายน้ำให้ว่ายน้ำทะเลหากไงว่ายน้ำ
ว่ายน้ำได้หน้าครูอาร์ทตี้ไวท์น้ำได้ไหม
คะอ่าได้ครอบครัวซิว่ายน้ำทะเลได้เก่งไหม
คะอ่ะ
ให้เก่งนิดหน่อย
จ่ายเขา
ว่าทะเลมีคลื่นค่ะลื่นชายทะเลมีคลื่นอ่ะ
อ่า
คู่เอกก็ว่ายน้ำที่ทะเลชอบแบบว่ายน้ำไม่
ขอขอขอไหว้ไม่เก่งไหมเก่งเหมือนกู Arty
Arty  vie ได้นิดหน่อยมีกันนิดหน่อยนะคะ
อ่าตี้ว่ายไปถึงตรงนี้ค่ะอ้าใช่ครับ
ประมาณอ่า 10 เมตร 10 เมตรใช้ครับ 50
เมตรแล้วก็กลับแล้วก็กลับใช่ครับขวดที่ 10
เมตรแล้วก็กลับ
เหนื่อยฮ่าๆแล้วก็กลับ
กินดีกว่าเนาะ
ชายเขา
ทะเลมีอย่างอื่นอีกไหมคะอันนี้มีน้ำทะเล
มีกัน
มีอะไรอีกคะอ้านี่ครับที่ทะเล
หาย
มีต้นมะพร้าวครับอ.พร้าวให้ครับมีลูกไหม
อ่ะต้นค่อยมีไม่มียังไม่มียังไม่มีอ้า
ต้องหาเจ๊เห็นดอกมะพร้าวจ่ายครับตรงนี้
ตรงนี้เป็นดอกมะพร้าว
Party วงได้ไหมคะดอกมะพร้าวอยู่ตรงนี้
ได้หน้ามะพร้าว
ครับมะพร้าว
เอาเราก็มีอะไรคะมะพร้าวอยู่ที่ไหนคะ R
มะพร้าวอยู่บอลหาดทรายสะอาดสะอาดสารทราย
ชายว้าวหัดตายห่วยๆ
มีที่ทะเลมีทะเลมีหาดทรายมีครับมะพร้าวมี
ดอกมะพร้าวนี่ใบใบมะพร้าวตายครับมีใบ
มะพร้าวเขียว
เมื่อเช้าอาบมีอย่างอื่นอีกไหมคะที่ถ่าย
มีครับที่ทะเลมีอ้าเดี๋ยวกลัวติด 5 เปิด
รูปอื่นอีกค่ะพี่เขาถามน่ะอ้ะใช่ครับ
มะพร้าวอีก 2  5 ใช่มีมะพร้าวนี่หนึ่งต้น
แล้วก็นี่ 1 ต้นหน้าแล้วก็โค๊ดตี้มี
มะพร้าวแล้วใต้ต้นมะพร้าวมะพร้าวข้างบน
มะพร้าวอายต้นมะพร้าวตรงนี้อ่าครับหน้ามี
อะไรคะตรงนี้ใช่ไหมครับอ่ะตรงนี้เป็น
เก้าอี้เก้าอี้เค้าที่ชายหาดใช้งับอยู่
ชายหาดตรงนี้เป็นชายหาดค่ะนี่อายหาดหานิด
แดงเก้าอี้
r9 อี้อิมิตโลกโดยไหมคะอ่ะใช่นะครับมี
โต๊ะอยู่ตรงนี้อ้าได้ครับโอเคเอาไว้ทำ
อะไรคะเขามีเขาไหมดอนนอนนอนดูดูทะเลก็ดู
จะนอนหลับนอนดูอ่ะนอนหลับได้ครับนอนดู
ทะเลก็ได้เหรอนอนหลับฮ่าๆๆกูอัดที่นอนดู
ถ้าใช้ครับนอนดูทะเลที่
มะพร้าวนะคะข้างหลังต้นมะพร้าวมีอะไรอ่ะ
คะอ๋ออ๋อข้างหลังหลังต้นมะพร้าวตรงนี้
หน้านี้นี่คือนี่เป็นซุ้มครับเป็นซุ้ม 5
สูง 5
ข้างล่างซุ้มมีอะไรนะคะๆข้างล่างซุ้มเป็น
เก้าอี้ชายหาด
และก็ซุ้มใช้กันอะไรคะอ้าซุ้มใช้กันแดดหอ
พระอาทิตย์อาจมีพระอาทิตย์อ่ะนี่ถ้า
อาทิตย์
ส่องแสงออกมาอ่ามีแดดมีได้มีแสงแต่แสงแดด
นี่ร้อนใช่ไหมค่ะแสงแดดร้อนครับ 5 ร้อนนะ
คะก็อ้ะ
เก้าอี้ชายหาดก็อยู่ใต้ซุ้มใต้อยู่ใกล้ผม
นามีอะไรคะเงาหรือเปล่าคะ 5 ตรงนี้ใช่ไหม
ครับหน้าเป็นเงาเงาใช่ครับตรงที่เป็นเงา
ไม่มีแดดออกก็ไม่ร้อนๆครับไม่ร้อนน่ะไม่
ร้อนนะครับซุ้มมีกี่ซุ้มครับว่าซุ้ม 2-0
ครับค่ะถ้า
อันไหนคะ
100 วันนี้
200 ทราย
สวยอ่ะครูแพทตี้ค่าครู Arty ไปใช้หาด
แฮปปี้จะนั่งที่เก้าอี้
ไหน 5 เก้าอี้ให้ต้นมะพร้าวไปตอนหนาวนี้
หรืออันนี้ก็อี้ใต้โสมอันนี้ก็อี้ใต้ต้น
มะพร้าว R ขั้วติ๊นั่งเก้าอี้ตายสุมครับ
ตายต้นมะพร้าวนะคะใจกับใต้ต้นมะพร้าวมี
แดดนี้ครับแสงแดดได้ใต้ซุ้มไม่มีแค่ส่วน
คู่ x แลัวลูกมะพร้าว
รูปมะพร้าวๆไม่มีให้แฟนดูก็ลองข้างบนออก
ไม่มะพร้าวโอเคถ้ามีมะพร้าวไม่เอาเขามีลม
แล้วมะพร้าวหล่นอ้าอันนี้อันนี้มีอันนี้
มีมะพร้าวนี่มีลูกมะพร้าว
ถลนตู้ที่โอ้ยลูกเมียความค่ะให้เขาด้วย
ไม่เอาฮ่าๆ
หากต้องต้อง
มองถ้าไม่มีโอเคค่าถ้ามีไม่เอานะคะไปที่
ซุ้งดีกว่า
กวนตี้มีอย่างอื่นอีกไหมคะอ่ะมีอย่างอื่น
อีกครับนี่ให้คะทะเลมีดีๆเรียกว่าอะไรคะ
นี่เรียกว่าแปลกครับขอแปลเองเพลงแขวนเอา
ไว้ที่ไหนข้อ 5 แขวนไว้ที่กิ่งไม้ได้ครับ
5 แขวนไว้ที่กิ่งไม้อ่ะนี่ครับอา
รต์เอาไว้ทำอะไรคะครูอ่านให้แปลเอาไว้
นั่ง
นางได้ให้ครับอ่าเดี๋ยวเรานั่งยังไงนั่ง
โอเค
น่าดูดู
ดูทะเลอ่าเรานอนก็ได้ครับ
5 ใส่ครับนอน Hey
แล้วเปก็อะไรนะไปเปย์ได้ใช่ครับ a ก็ควาย
ไปอ่ะควายๆได้ครับควายไปมาๆๆๆๆ
ควายเปน
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
อ๋อ
เหรอกู Arty ครับเห็นนะค่ะอ่ะเมย์ใช่ไหม
คะข้างหลังเลไกลๆก็ข้างหลังแปลไปไกลๆตรง
โน้นใช่ไหมลงนอนใช่ไหมอะค่ะนั้น
เรียกเกาะเกาะให้ครับเกาะ 5 เกาะสองเกาะ
นะคะๆครับ R  R มีเกาะอยู่ในทะเลใกล้ๆ
ทรายอ่าเห็นแล้วคิดอยากนอน
ๆ
น้องทิพย์แลแล้วก็ควายเรยฮ่าๆๆมีความสุข
งาม
ทะเล
มีอย่างอื่นอีกไหมคะอ้ามีครับเวลาไปทะเล
ร้องหน้า
ร้อนอ่ะอยากดื่มน้ำ
เฮ้ยอยากดื่มน้ำน้าใช้สาว
น้ำร้อน
ที่ทะเลร้อนๆครับดื่มเย็นๆดื่มน้ำเย็นเขา
ว่า
แดดร้อนได้ครับ
รับอะไรบ้างคะครัวมีน้ำไปทะเลต้องมีน้ำ
ฮันนี้ครับน้ำมะพร้าว
โอ้ยตัวเองชอบเอา
น้ำมะพร้าววางที่ไหนอ่ะกูอัดนะมะพร้าววาง
ก้อนหินให้เขานั่งอยู่บนก้อนหินอ่าบนก้อน
หินอยู่ที่ถ่ายทะเลวางวางบน
แก้วแก้ววางบนมืออ้ามาวางบนมือ
อันนั้น
มะพร้าวไม่ครับเราบอกมะพร้าวอ่อนเนาะหา
ใช่เป็นมะพร้าวอ่อน
สีเขียวนะมะพร้าวอ่อนวางบนก้อนหิน
อายแล้วเขาก็เปิดฝาใสไหมคะเปิดเปิดป่า
มะพร้าวแล้วมีอะไรคะสีขาวหามีหลอดนี่ครับ
มีหลอดเอาไว้หวยทำให้มีดูดน้ำอาบน้ำ
มะพร้าวทราย
ไม่ดีครับมันจะ 6  6 ปีอาๆต้องใช้หลอดดู
อยากกินมะพร้าวฮ่าๆๆไม่ต้องจริงๆห้องกู
ไอ้หนาวนะแล้วตอนนี้ครูเหตุดูดูภาพอ่าของ
ครูอาชีพคูเอกร้อนนะอยากจะกินสาวก็อยาก
กินมะพร้าวอาญากินน้ำมะพร้าว
แล้วข้างบนมีมีอะไรคะข้างบนมีสับปะรดครับ
อันน่าน้ำสับปะรดใช่ไหมคะขับรถใช่ครับน้ำ
สับปะรดอยู่ในสับปะรด
จะปั่นปั่นแล้วครับปั่นปั่นแล้วก็
ใต้หาใช้หลอดดูดได้เดี๋ยวมีร่มด้วยอ่ะฮ่า
ๆ
มีร่มสับปะรดไม่ร้อนมีอยู่ร่ม
แล้วก็มีสตรอเบอร์รี่ได้ครับมีสตอเบอรี่
มีมะนาว
เล็กๆมะนาวเล็กๆอ่ะ
แล้วที่ติดกับน้ำสับปะรดเต็มแก้วหานี้ใน
แก้วนี้น้ำชาน้ำชาน้องชาใส่น้ำแข็ง
เย็น 5 เป็นเรียบชาเย็น chayen ในคะอาญา
เย็น
อีก 1 แก้วน้ำอะไรคะ 5 อีก 1 แก้วแก้วนี้
เจ้านี้น้ำมะนาวนี่มีมะนาวเป็นน้ำมะนาว
ครับมีมะนาวแล้วมีสีเขียวๆใบสะระแหน่ไหม
อ่ะสีเขียวเขียวๆๆแน่นะนักเรียนครัวที่
คิดว่าสะระแหน่เค้าจะไม่รู้ภาพอะไรอ่ะ
สะระแหน
เพราะว่าชนะแน่มีมีอะไรไปละเมินอ่ะเป็น
เปอร์มินต์ Mint อ่าเอ้าไม่ใช่แบบไทยนะ
อ่ะอ่ะและน้ำมะนาวครูเอกคิดนะมะนาวโซดาขอ
ขอขอ
น้ำมะนาวมีโซดาเก๋เป็นโซดาก็เย็นเย็นหน้า
ไอ้นะเปรี้ยวนิดหน่อยเย็นๆเปรี้ยวเปรี้ยว
ๆกู Arty  Happy  Shop ดื่มน้ำอะไรคะครัว
ตี้ชอบน้ำชาเย็นมามากใช่ครับมากดที่สุด
เลยใช่ครับสุดที่สุดโอเค
แล้วครูเอ๋เอ๋
ชอบน้ำอะไรครับคูเอก Shop ชอบน้ำมะพร้าว
สับปะรดถ้าภาวนา
Soda
อ๋ออ๋อครูเอกชอบ 3 อย่างเลยชอบน้ำมะพร้าว
มีน้ำสับปะรดแล้วก็น้ำมะนาวโซดานามาตาม
ไม่ชอบน้ำชาอ๋อสวัสดีหัวตีชอบแนวสักที่
สุดถ้าอาหารน้ำชากูเอกกินชาร้อนท่อสินชาว
ร้อนใช้เย็นคูลแอบไม่ถึงออกนี่หน่อยนะๆ
โอเคชอบมะพร้าวค่ะอ๋ออ๋อชอบมะพร้าวมาก
กว่าชาเย็นเวลาร้อนๆร้อนดื่มน้ำมะพร้าว
อ๋อร้อนเนี้ยหายไปอ๋อ
มาก
แล้วมีอะไรอีกค่ะกูอันตี้เวลาไปทะเลเรา
ต้องมีนี้ครับอ๋อเพราะว่าทำไมทะเลร้อนใช่
ไหมร้อนใช่ครับทะเลหน้าร้อนเอ้อมีแสงแถบ
ให้ครับมีแสงแบบแล้วร้อนๆงั้นผิวเนี่ยใช่
ไหมคะได้ครับเปลี่ยนเป็นสีสีดำ
สีดำร้อนมากหรือพอมากสีดำแล้วที่นี้จะขอ
50 มอบออกมานี้อยู่แล้วผิวหนังเนี่ยก็
บอกผิวไม่อ๋อไม่ไม่อาจไม่เพราะแดดร้อน
ร้อนมาก
มากรู้จะไม่หนึ่งวันสองวันสามวันจะลอกนอก
เหรอ
ให้ดีต้องมีอะไรคะครู
ครีมกันแดดๆฟิล์มใช่ไหมคะแดดเอ่อออกไปได้
ครับไม่ไม่ไม่ลอก
ครับแต่ร้อนร้อนๆไม่ลอกร้อนแตกไม่ลอกให้
เรา
เหมือน
[เพลง]
ครูแอ๊ดอิ๊ดใช้ครีมกันแดดไหมคะถ้าครัวตี้
ใช้นิดหน่อยน้อ
ร้อน OK  I ครับสีดำโอเคอ่าใช้ขับไม่เป็น
ไรดำนะครับไม่เป็นไรเชิญค่ะอ่ะไม่เป็นไร
ครับดำนิดหน่อยไม่เป็นไรแล้วเวลาร้อนอ่ะ
ผิวครูอาทิรอไปคะผิวสีดำ R ในลอกครับไม่
นอน
กูดีหัวเหน่าก่อนดูรอบๆหน้าห่าขั่วตี้ควร
ตี้ตากแดดแป๊บเดียวไม่นานไม่นานไม่ลอกออก
คู๋
10  11  12  1  2  3  4
ประมาณ
8-9 ชั่วโมง
โอ้ยนานนานผิวลอบก็ไม่ใช้ 1 วันค่าค่าวัน
นี้งู
ที่น่าสีดำแล้วก็เอิ่มอ๋อฮ่าๆหน้ารอบหน้า
แขน
ลอก
แสนแขนไม่หรอกน่าขอหน้าลอกหน้าลอก
แขนโอเคและ
ก็ตอนนี้เวลาไปทะเลครูเอกก็ต้องมีครีมใช่
ค่ะน้องทาทาครีมกันแดดอ่ะอ่าดีกันได้มัน
ไม่งั้นจะผิวจะ
ชายพิมพ์ให้
ผิวไม่แล้วไปทะเลมีครีมกันแดดแล้วมีอะไร
อีกคะอ้ามีครีมกันแดดแล้วต้องมีนี่ด้วย
ครับนี่เป็นนี่เป็นอะไรคะแว่นครับแว่น
แว่นกันแดดแว่นกันแดดเหมือนกันอ่ะครับ
แว่นกันแดดหน้ากูเอกเขามีแวะกันแดดโอเคๆ
นี่ไงกันแดดสอนได้ไหมคะ
ได้ให้อาทิตนักเรียนโอเคไว้ในบ้านครูเอ๋
มีแบบไหนครับมีมีไฟค่ะตอนนี้ไม่มีแดดไม่
แอบแดกไม่ต้องใส่เขากันกันไฟการไฟอ๋อโอเค
แว่นไม่กันแดดกันไฟนะแต่ว่ามองไม่เห็น
Arty เอาออกจาก
เท Army แว่นกันแดดมันต้องมีแว่นกันแดดนะ
คะก็สีดำเนาะนายครับแว่นกันแดดสีดำบางที
ก็สีน้ำเงินนะคิดสีน้ำอะมีมีแว่นกันแดดมี
สีน้ำเงินด้วยแล้วก็มีสีสีเหลือง
มีหลายสีวันที่สีเหลืองนะฮะไปครับก็มี
อะตี้ครีมกันแดดแล้วอ้ามีแว่นกันแดดแล้ว
มีแว่นกันแดดอะไรอีกคะทีมกันแดดมีแว่นกัน
แดดแล้วก็ก็ต้องมีนี่ครับต้องมี
ม่วงมีหมวดเสื้อ
กันแดดใช่ไหมมันแดกเหมือนกันน้ำ
กันแดดอ่าครับมีม่วงมีหมวกด้วยโอ้โห
หน้าครูเอ๋ไปเลย
เดี๋ยวหมดเวลาหรือยังจะไปทะเลแล้ว
ครับหนึ่งขอยังไปไม่ได้เลยเขาอยู่กับนัก
เรียนก่อนมาอยู่กับนักเรียนก่อนอะตี้มี
รูปทะเลขอไปทะเลอยากกันแดดออก a  r ออกนะ
ฮะโอเคค่ะอ้าบวกเราก็ใส่ที่หัวน้องๆใส่
หัวกันแดดเหมือนกันแต่
ได้ครับ
ถ้ามีอะไรอีกคะอ่าจะเอาอะไรไปอีกอ้ะปวด
ตี้จะเอานี่ไปด้วยครับอันสุดท้ายที่ครูนะ
พี่จะออกไปทะเลอันนี้ครับนี่อะไรอ่านี่
คือรองเท้าแตะหอร้องเท้าแตะรองเท้าแต่
สำหรับสำหรับใส่อะไรครับเดินๆ
เพราะว่าที่ทะเลมีหน้าตาตายมีน้ำค่ะใช่
ครับใส่รองเท้าแตะดีดีกว่า
รองเท้าสำหรับวิ่งไม่ได้ใช่ไหมคะไม่ได้
ไม่ได้เปียกน้ำชายเปลี่ยนน้ำได้เปียกน้ำ
รองเท้าแตะเปียกได้เคใช้ครับ
ก็มีมีอะไรดีแว่นกันแดดแว่นกันแดดกันแดด
ได้ครับแก้ปวดกับรองเท้าห้าใช่ข้าวไหม
พอแล้วไปได้แล้วครับโอเคได้แล้วไม่ต้องมี
ชุดว่ายน้ำชุดว่ายน้ำ
อาเราไว้ข่าวหน้าหอ
เรามีเราจะเอาชุดว่ายน้ำไปด้วยอ้ากฎเวลา
นักเรียนจริงๆคนไทยไม่มีชุดว่ายน้ำก็โอเค
นะใช่อ๋อคลิปนี้หมดเวลาแล้วนะคะหางาน
เนี่ยนักเรียนก็ดูแล้วก็รู้ว่าวันนี้ครู
อาชีพพาไปทะเลเสียงทะเลเห็นน้ำทะเล
ชายหาดห้างเห็นต้นมะพร้าวๆ
กันแดดขาวโอเคค่ะงั้นครู Arty ก็คู๋ไป
ก่อนเนาะใต้ขอลาไปก่อนครับวันนี้ 5
สวัสดีครับนักเรียนทุกคนอ่ะแค่นั้นสวัสดี
ครับพี่เอ๋
My  Side  By  My